nach einer 45 leute gerne aber jetzt
nicht kümmern sich verschieben und ja
darum ein spiel alleine bestimmt nicht
mathematik oder ein bisschen leiser hin
3 nein sagte mann du bist fertig und
dann ich bin auch fertig jetzt im
anfangen hallo meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zurück in der today
show zusammen mit den ardennen endlich
eine vernünftige minecraft john slade
zumindest hoffen wir dass die noch
einmal neu gestaltet ach so du hast du
bist ja gleich wieder unten dann kann
man schon mal sagen trainer wie sagte
zen meister man wird sehen
es war sehr gut angebracht habe ich hier
die rolle vorsprechen überblicke drei
obsidian wie viele brauchen batteln
bittet thomas fleisch doch mal rein
wo hat mir endlich mal den versorgungs
tisch stehen bei mir im wohnzimmer dafür
wie wir bauen sondern extra kleines
häuschen dafür irgendwo hatten wir
eigentlich oben in der pyramide aber
dann wurde daher alles geklaut von
irgendwelchen komischen grabes prämien
ich meine dann extra sie nicht stören
plötzlich so wie du konntest du ja du
nämlich ich wäre dafür wie bond sondern
so ein kleines kleine ruine da irgendwo
hin
ich finde es eigentlich auch cool damit
da im
in der pyramide dringend ziemlich cool
oder nicht ich fand wieder eigentlich
ziemlich klage will kann in unserem
komischen steinen dings ich dachte jetzt
irgendwo aus moos stein und alle
möglichen baumann ist ein kleine ruin
sagte stone age und pack in der mitte
den tisch das ist jetzt erst mal ob sie
den schergen des ministers als bringt
darf dafür 43 obsidian ob sie noch
welche farm oder hast du noch welche ich
hab mit nur 18 mal nachschauen
bitte nicht 12
ich werde auch eine richtig richtig
fette fahr mal einfach bauen kann ich
will irgendwas mit redstone machen wie
viel hatte ich noch habe ich gesagt 4
oder 1 33
übrigens zuerst setzten thema thema den
auf dem rückweg und dann kann ich dir
ein thema schlafen immer unten in der
höhle in bist du bei dir unten
runtergegangen oder bis zum meister
gesucht ich habe eine neue hürde
irgendwo von habe ich eh wieder raus
weil ich muss auch klein auf neue höhen
suppe ihnen hier einfach nichts
unmögliches nichts drin
nein com formieren
sz war noch keiner den bereichen dann
komme ich noch nicht nach hause weil
hier ist viel
ja ich kann mein thema auch schon ist
eine stop auf facebook hat geschrieben
und zwar bitte beim aufrechten schreibt
nicht eine sondern ist mir aufgefallen
letzten wochen das versetze ich habe
daraus gemacht übrigens an einer
pinnwand dass man darauf schreiben kann
ich konnte trotzdem schreiben 100 wie ja
ich konnte trotzdem noch schreiben ich
habe es gemacht weil er wirklich 100
prozent nur werbung und scheiße fragen
an kam also 100% werbung scheiße und in
welche fragen die schon antwort hat und
sonst halt nur so keine ahnung bilder so
zwar ganz schön aber die können wir dann
auch einfach bei twitter zeigen oder
dann irgendwie per nachricht senden oder
so aber wirklich bei diesen facebook
links wo wir größtenteils gepostete
deswegen deswegen hat er scania die
schade sowie auch bei facebook
nachrichten youtube das größte mist ist
da ist auch viel sinnvolles dabei aber
so viel mist dass es sinnvoller häufig
untergeht und das ist natürlich gar
nicht der sinn des ganzen
eine schlucht gefunden und die ist so im
wasser und das will ich gerade den
wasserfall hoch der darunter kommt dann
bin ich wieder aus derschlag draußen
es ist sehr sieht sehr schön aus auch
toll und so eine thema dena ist dran und
zwar gehst du zum video die 2013
frank du mal da bin ich mein gott
also ich na ja ich habe mich werde
höchstwahrscheinlich da hingehen kann
das jetzt noch nicht hundertprozentig
sagen aber ich werde
höchstwahrscheinlich dort hingehen und
das ist ja zeitgleich mit der gamescom
aber es ist nicht mehr auf dem gamescom
gelände wie bisher und hat auch ein
verlangt eigenen eintritt spricht ich
weiß nicht wann ich glaube ich
frühbucherpreise wie 16 17 euro oder
sind 20 euro also relativ teuer aber ist
halt auch eine ganze halten die da ist
und mit mit großem programm und einem
möglichen ist auch auf facebook auf der
video der seite alles nachlesbar
während ich mich echt ich mich mal auf
element suche begeben seiner oder 2 ich
finde das eine super sache das ist halt
so ein großes youtuber treffen in
deutschland gibt wo man hingehen kann
mit in amerika gilt kostet 100 euro und
ist eine komplette messe sozusagen
luftbad aus scheiße da ich kann mit
meinen schwert die nicht die nicht
fahren weil die sich wenn weckt ihn wenn
die brennen das will ich packe ich nehme
zur dschungel dschungel holz mit und
diese komischen kakaobohne machen wir
uns damals noch eine farm im
außengelände da hinten dann denken wir
uns einfach mal machen
juli ich habe auch schon ändert alles
echt
bis dahin war da gerade gestorben ich
gehört aber irgendwie keine perle
dropped ich habe bock im dschungel
tempel besucher nicht ob das mache ich
jetzt mal hin
ich höre ja was sagst du zu mir day war
ich werde
mann ich möchte endlich mal etwas tolles
finden so wie im dschungel tempel oder
seinen wüsten dorf oder allgemein pc
dorf alles was schön ist du hast schon
mal den tc aufgefunden ja ich glaube ich
mache jetzt mal hier unseren unserem
fritzen da ganz ganz viel sorgt herr
wiese sind die blöcke
mal schauen ob es schon darum ist er
nichts es kann sein weiß nicht genau ob
der überhaupt eine höhere gemeinschaft
denkt ist einfach gestorben sind schon
fackeln ich wollte jetzt für sich bei
dir ja und ohne abzustürzen bisher wer
weiß
dreimal auf holz klopfen ich hatte einen
tag wieder ab ging's ab runter gefahren
weil der pc über nacht als geändert hat
sap crm einmal alle zehn minuten stunden
einfach mal so ab wenn ich den so auch
bald schulzeit laufen beim
hochwasserschutz einfach mal so zwischen
eltern weil er einfach damit nicht
klarkommen wir das etwas schlechter pcs
sehen ich habe das werten von 100 oder
mich getäuscht so ein studium das ist
jetzt ein bisschen schnee mit
bereit etwas tag ein bisschen jetzt tag
zwei männer ein habe ich für mit
feuerwehr verjagt und eine zweite
relativ spät
alle angst vor mir man so sieht nämlich
aus solchen alle angst haben aber das
jetzt schon was ein video der gesagt nur
so halbwegs ja ich habe gesagt dass
nicht hingehen werde aus den gründen das
ich find's einfach nur scheiße 20 euro
bezahlen zu müssen
auch egal wenn es in amerika als ich
finde einfach keine ahnung ich weiß doch
dass man dafür geld bezahlen muss
irgendwie müssen wir bezahlen ja aber es
meine meinung ich möchte dafür kein geld
bezahlen und zweite sache keine ahnung
also ich meine ich habe mir kurzzeitig
überlegt mich dann auch zu zeigen und so
dass die leute mich treffen können aber
ehrlich gesagt habe ich da auch wenn mir
ruckelt das auch echt ich schlüpfe
gerade dachten erklärt durch die gegend
wie sagten das so sagt man habe keine
ahnung also auf der gamescom werde ich
wahrscheinlich gehen ich weiß nicht ob
ich mich vorher nie zeigen werde
den anwalt aus aber ich weiß noch nicht
genau so für gamescom werde ich gehen
weil mich das interessiert aber beim
videodreh keine ahnung ich guck kaum
deutsche youtube ich meine das ist für
mich das nicht es lohnt sich für mich
nicht 18 euro auszugeben und den
sonderzug center fand jetzt auch nicht
so toll für mich zum beispiel
unsicherheit gamescom interessiert mich
wenig so ist meister man steht ja
eigentlich fast nur angefahren seit zwei
oder drei jahren zu games kommen und ich
weiß ich also es ist halt dass ich zudem
entwickelte ich meinen einfach so ein
bisschen chillen darüber laufen alles
mal so ein bisschen angucken was neues
kommt dann einfach so das kann man
machen aber ich weiß nicht wie der jetzt
in einer extra gebäude und dann damit
youtube oder sich weiß ich ich schau dir
halt nicht ich weiß keine ahnung lohnt
sich für mich nicht einfach
ich finde halt eben das was du gesagt
dass beide games kommen eben einfach
herumlaufen und und als man das ist auch
für mich beim video teilhaber leute
treffen und alles mögliche und 20 euro
realismus als bezahlt was ich meine
das wird ja immer gesagt hat wir wollen
jetzt alle geldgeil youtube noch geld
das man sie trifft wir bekommen dafür
keinen cent ich weiß nicht ob die
auftreten daraus bekommen aber bisher
was eigentlich so und das alles dient
nur zur refinanzierung der ganzen halle
man kann er nach schon wie teuer so ist
die langener damen an ihren taten im
nachhinein anders damit gewinn machen
werden aber keine ahnung bis zum wald
nicht ganz genau
ich kann nur sagen dass ich auf jeden
fall alltag ist eine fette schlucht eine
sehr sehr große stunde seine wucht
gesehen glaube ich ich weiß nicht wie
viel davon jetzt wirklich darin
die refinanzierung geht und wie viel da
wirklich dann kommerz gemacht wird ich
weiß nicht sag mal bist du die
koordinaten für unser haus und heute
stimmt hat immer ungefähr -120 und x2
170 - 200 und 270 kleinhaus jetzt
endlich in der höhle rein so genaue
vorschau und so die richtung
da wir wollen auch noch fackeln und
fackeln irgendwo kind gar nicht
zurechtgewiesen minecraft alles
vollkommen skizziert hast jetzt ein ende
augen einfach in die kommentare
schreiben
beim videodreh oder auf der gamescom
wette dabei bleiben und warum einfach
mal ergründet werden wahrscheinlich
seien ja ich gehe dahin weil ich wieder
treffe oder ich gehe da nicht hin weil
20 außer mir zu teuer und ich wohl ganz
woanders ist wahrscheinlich die
hauptrunde aber können ja trotzdem
reinstetten okay ich hab nämlich
zurückgefunden und ich muss nur neue
fackelmann fucking fackeln erfolg eine
coleman 16x vorjahr 16 6 27 9 16 62
reinholz wahrscheinlich da wo heute
ansteht
nein immer inventar achja kisten muss ja
auch mal sortieren ja vorher übrigens
wir haben haben diesmal keinen gast weil
wir einfach so aber noch gar nicht
gesagt haben wir in der letzten folge
nicht gesagt wir haben kein gast weil
wir einfach so ein bisschen mal ein
bisschen ruhe reinbringen wollte und so
ein bisschen uns um kirsten sortierung
und so ein bisschen produktiver sein
wollten ja und vor allem auch weil wir
moment so wenig zum aufräumen gekommen
sind weil du café mit der schule zu tun
hat und jetzt halten wir jetzt können
wir den gerade mal auf jetzt passt
gerade mal so kann irgendjemand nein
kann ich kann gar nicht gleich
möchtegern aber jetzt genau heute gehe
ich ja später gerne mal allein nach
einer 45 leute weiter gerne aber jetzt
nicht verschieben und ja darum ein spiel
alleine
nachhilfe verständnis jetzt nicht abgabe
ist alten nicht ich gehe jetzt haben
doppelt ich muss sagen ich weiß nicht
ich weiß nicht was ich machen könnte
als boston was machst du gerade ich geh
jetzt eine höhle ich gehe den weg der
milch eine hülle bin wohl noch niemand
war und von pharmig plan und so ich weiß
nicht wie weit ich weggehen soll
ich weiß nicht ob es ihr dann schon neu
generiert wird oder nicht zu ihrem ein
interessantes wird der wald weg gehen
berlin trotz links bekommt jetzt eine
große schlappe war noch keiner
wenn patrick das nicht von irgendetwas
sein war ich glaube dass er tacke vom 15
doppelschlag perfekt ab ja ich komme
wieder zur farm lauf und da so ein
bisschen wenn union in rot gesprungen
ich denke auch mal so wenn ihr immer
runterspringen besuchen überlebe ich das
man sprechen darunter andere bauen sich
daran runtermachen davon hackmack muss
ich einfach viel islam leben jungen
linken bisschen meego lospech läutet das
hilft juli hilft auch gegen die schlimme
twitter erkrankungen die jetzt auch im
umlauf ist welche die twitter
erkrankungen den leuten sollte man doch
am besten folgen wieder von twitter
betroffen sind sorgen ist das
nachgefragt ich könnte nachgefragt ist
noch nicht die auftritte ab und ich habe
auch auf der gamescom schon foto mit
push it tv
ich weiß ja komisch ich mit meiner
kamera teams mit dem mit meiner kamera
obwohl er selber einen namen dafür diese
ganzen linie zum herbst haben wir auch
ein bisschen glück das ich jetzt habe
ich ob sie dem ja nicht alle aber viele
kleine hühner
grüne wo er hier so eine riesen der a20
beschlossen und jetzt ist hier noch mal
eine unter wunsch schlucht rabbiner
denkst ich hätte ich auch was für eine
höhe bieten hier 14 man also wenn hier
keine diamanten zu finden sind
dann wäre ich ja auch nicht freundlich
ab ich finde wie gesagt geht es ja
welche ab zwei stück dafür hatte ich
einfach diabetes einfach du hast keine
gefallen und packten änderte das kann
man alles war dachte du bist jetzt
hinter mir brauchst die erde aprilia
schritt wolle man wieder zeugen ich
mache jetzt erst mit den schaden von den
ort wieder heile morgen wieder vorbei
ist vorbei die partnervereine wie man
seiner könnt ihr eine positive bewertung
überlassen